it's great to be joined today by Brian
cloths who's a fellow in global and
comparative politics at the London
School of Economics also author of the
book the desperate accomplice How the
West is aiding and abetting the decline
of democracy it's so great to have you
on I think as a sort of general
principle we would consider that at the
world level we've seen more democracy
since the Cold War and you argue in the
book that we've now seen a reversal in
that so I guess the first question is
how do we measure democracy in the world
sure that's a good question so you're
absolutely right we had a massive surge
in democracy through the 1980s 90s and
early 2000 so Latin America democratized
me 80s then we had Eastern Europe and
sub-saharan Africa the 90s after the
Berlin Wall fell and then it started to
switch and this tipping point happened
around 2006 according to the major
indices this doesn't happen always with
you know coos or civil wars or you know
massive authoritarian grabs of power
it's a slippage of what a lot of
political scientists called Democratic
backsliding but basically there's a lot
of indicators that look at the quality
of democracy and the harsh reality is
that for 11 years we've been going in
the wrong direction so authoritarianism
is on the march and democracy is in
retreat and what are some of the I mean
generally we've talked a lot about
authoritarianism certainly in the last
year's a year and a half but what are
some of the more specific indicators if
we were to sort of create some kind of
democracy score or mean or something
like that
what sort of cycle can we look at so
election quality is certainly one of
them how free and fair elections are
there's also press freedom there's other
aspects about how basically civil
society is treated how democratic the
process that the rule of law is in
making laws there's a whole variety of
others there's a few different indices
polity for does one freedom house does
another there's one called varieties of
democracy that's a think-tank in Sweden
so you know there's a variety different
ways of measuring it but the unifying
thread all of these different
measurement
so they're seeing the same trend this
doesn't mean the Democratic sky is
falling so you know more people live in
democracy in human history
now they sleep than any other time
except for you know the peak about a
decade ago so we're still doing
relatively well by historic standards in
a long long trend but we are looking at
a consistent and very troubling decline
and I'm worried that right now with
policy changes that are happening
sweeping around the world that decline
is actually getting worse before it gets
better
are there or is there a place I guess is
the question when we think about
democracy for factors such as income
inequality for example or economic
mobility right the idea of how easily
can one move out of poverty if they are
born into poverty for example are those
factors that have a role to play in
thinking about democracy around the
world yeah so if you if you think about
the actual word democracy comes from two
greek words demos and craftiness and i
think what you're referring to is
usually lumped into the process so the
demos is the people the rule of the
people and the process is the power and
this is where you know democracy itself
is only good insofar as it actually
generates results for people so I say
very clearly in the book and I don't
think this is a terribly controversial
statement but it's one you don't think
about it that often is you'd probably
not rather be born in Bennett in West
Africa even though it's a democratic
state compared to Singapore which is an
authoritarian state because you have to
basically work for 65 years in Benin in
order to receive the same salary you
probably would get in Singapore and at
some point the right to vote is not
worth that much to a lot of people so I
think what's what a lot of people have
lost track of is that democracy can be a
world and basic good no matter what
because it's important to have people
how to say in the government but it also
has to deliver and I think one thing
that's hollowed out the quality of
democracy in the West that has given
rise to populism is a lot of people
living in democratic states have seen
their wages stagnate they haven't been
able to get ahead and they're starting
to turn to alternative models or return
to ways of thinking and I think that's a
mistake even though I think it's also a
wake-up call
we need to reinvigorate the quality of
our democracy hmm as far as populism is
concerned we've talked a lot on the
program about how you can have sort of
similar sounding populist rhetoric from
potential or actual elected officials
but that in terms of governance there's
a pretty big difference between what
we've sort of called progressive
populism versus regressive populism can
you talk a little bit about how the
populist message more broadly cannot
always directly relate to whether we're
going to see an increase or decrease in
democracy or sort of how populist
rhetoric can maybe muddy the waters in
some sense yeah so I mean a lot of the
surge in popular around the world let's
if we look outside the West sort of
stereotypical cases of you know the rise
of populism in France right now or in
the u.s. around the world you typically
have a liberal populism so this is where
you know you have echoes of this in the
West in the sense of Donald Trump's
message of I alone can fix it it's sort
of an illiberal populist message it's
blending authoritarian rhetoric along
with this idea that the little guy needs
somebody else to look out for them I
mean the irony of all this is that very
often the standard bearers of populism
are the ones who take advantage of
inequality to ride to political office
and then make political and economic
inequality worse once they get there and
that's what's happening in the u.s.
right now and I would argue will
probably accelerate under-under for
example Trump's tax plan but you know
the aspect that I think was the really
big missed opportunity is that there is
a genuine possibility for people in the
last the center-left etc to say we
messed up we have basically ignored at
the center of our country the center of
our economy for 30 years we haven't done
enough to blunt the sharp edges of
globalization but we're going to do this
in a way that is about you know bridges
rather than walls it's about trying to
actually create strategies to fix the
problems rather than just simply
demonize people and blame them for them
so you know I think that's the real
missed opportunity that's happened in
the West and that's something that's
very dangerous because the more people
believe that all
Oh tix is bad and that's part of what
populist messages the more that they
turn to figures who are simply
opportunists and I think that's what
we're seeing in a lot of places where
you know scapegoating is not actually a
strategy and when people begin to
realize that robots and automation are
much bigger threat to them than China or
Mexico or immigrants or whatever it is
they need somebody to pick up the pieces
and I'm hoping that you know as the sort
of tide switches back towards the adults
so to speak the people who have skills
and qualifications there needs to be
somebody ready to pick up that mantle
who can speak the populist language but
also have a pragmatic strategy Brian as
far as religion is concerned not in a
sort of abstract way but specifically as
we've seen it applied around the world
since the Cold War can we make a general
assessment about whether religion is
currently a pro or anti-democratic
influence in the world yeah I mean it's
very mixed I would say I think the
religion has been exploited for
authoritarian reasons sometimes but very
often in history remember of some of the
most tyrannical governments are
completely secular and actually used the
tools of the state to dismantle religion
I think you know it's it's somewhat
neutral to in a sense depends on how
it's used and how it's sort of you know
employed in pursuit of a specific
ideology but I would say that you know
there's there's this there is a trend I
mean this has been identified for for a
long time there's a famous article in
political science called Mick world
versus jihad and this idea of are we
going to be this big global force which
has maybe less room for religious local
government for example or are we going
to have sort of these village based
politics tribal politics and feeling
like we can only look out for ourselves
and not for the other and religion
certainly comes into that divide so you
know I think that there's certainly a
place for religion in the modern world
as long as it is not simply used to
divide people and what I think is really
dangerous is when you have an illiberal
populist message and authoritarian
wrapped up in a foreign rhetoric
that then uses religion as a tool or a
weapon so you know I don't think it's
anything that to make me good or bad I
think it just depends on how people
exploit it or choose to work along the
lines of those values that people hold
in thinking about American foreign
policy for a second there are those in
the United States who have more
interventionist leanings and part of
that is based around this idea of
spreading democracy we heard that from
the George W Bush administration for
example is there any way we can assess
whether Western efforts to quote spread
democracy actually have a pro-democratic
influence sort of in the net sure so one
of the chapters of the book is very
explicitly says no more democracy wars
right so first off I think we need to
make really clear that trying to spread
democracy by the barrel of the gun does
not work and it's very often
counterproductive and what's even worse
than a lot of people don't think about
is this tipping point of the retreat of
democracy in 2006 I think is very
largely linked to the Iraq war and the
fact that authoritarian regimes around
the world were able to credibly claim
that any sort of u.s. pressure in
support of human rights or pro-democracy
NGOs on the ground or whatever was just
a Trojan horse to prepare for regime
change and the Iraq war gave them that
credibility because they could point to
it and say look they did it elsewhere so
what ended up happening was all the
sudden these regimes around the world
started purging NGOs for formers etc and
just saying this is the precursor to a
CIA tactic or a US invasion and of
course it wasn't the case but they have
the legitimacy to say that because the
Iraq war the second aspect of this is I
think that there's a very big problem
with how our foreign policy signals
things abroad and this is what I'm most
worried about now I think the u.s. can
actually legitimately spread democracy
effectively if it doesn't right but
what's happening now is sort of a
perfect storm of every bad thing the US
could do and what I mean by that is that
over the weekend you had Trump inviting
Rodrigo Duterte of the Philippines to
the White House right he embraced
President Sisi of Egypt he congratulated
President Erdogan of Turkey on rigging a
referendum that dismantled democracy
within a NATO ally and people around the
world I mean one thing we don't think
about I love it often but I saw you know
in my travels from Madagascar to Belarus
etc was every regime around the world
looks to Washington for cues about what
it can get away with and when you had
those signals coming out of the White
House it is extremely counterproductive
and and it sends a signal that the u.s.
doesn't even care anymore you know one
of the things that I found striking was
I went back to Trump's old tweets and I
found that he is tweeted as of yesterday
he tweeted for the 247th time about
crowds right he's tweeted about human
rights once and the only time he tweeted
about them was to mock Secretary of
State John Kerry for caring about them
so when you have that message you know
every government around the world sees
that and thinks you know if we torture a
few journalists I don't really think
that's going to be a big deal to trump
and they're probably right so you know I
think that it takes a very smart
strategy which is you know I outlined
ten principles for how the US can be
more effective in the book but I think
that we are going down a very dark path
where the president is actually
cheerleading these terrible governments
as opposed to acting like a referee that
can push them to follow the rules well
the book is incredibly timely again it's
called the despot sakam plus how the
West is aiding and abetting the decline
of democracy we've been speaking with
the book's author Brian cloths Brian
thanks so much for talking to me today
it's my pleasure thanks for having on
the show